hi i'm dan marshall and i'm here to show
you what my colleague dave brown has
built which is an immersive 3d data
visualization application so here we've
got some tornado data that we're showing
sort of in a scatter plot of tornadoes
happening in the united states and
they're just mapped out onto this map
here and the color of the dots that you
see here represent the strength of that
tornado if we go to another
visualization you'll see that these each
tornado that's represented by a circle
on the screen will get animated to a
different location so you see a lot of
tornadoes happening all in the same
place and as we can rotate this map well
we don't really know exactly how many
tornadoes are happening in that one
place so what one thing we can do is
stack them up vertically and now you can
see that more tornados happened in this
area over here in the Colorado area also
in this Florida area as we zoom into
this map here you can see each tornadoes
as represented as a cube
it went from a sphere transformed into a
cube onto the screen here going to the
next visualization you see the Tornado
Alley sort of effect as we take that
original scatterplot and cast it into
the z-axis in the third dimension by
time so that you can see sort of all the
tornados happening all at once here and
that animation you can see from going
from that scatterplot map view into a
bar chart view each tornado this
animated across the screen so that you
see that same data being laid out in a
different way according to the way that
you the chart that you want to use so in
this visualization we see that may is
the month with the most tornadoes and
you can zoom in to see once again each
each tornado there
in this visualization we've just moved
those tornadoes and now we can see the
hour of the day when they happen the
most which is around five o'clock in the
afternoon and now here we're showing the
tornados which year so around 2003 to
2005 we probably saw the most number of
tornadoes in that year we have another
way of telling stories with data and
here what we're going to show you is a
scrollable way to navigate through a
story with the data on the left and a
story on the right now here each square
represents a person who was on the
Titanic and we've got sort of a page
here illustrating that the data
visualization that you're seeing on the
left and we've cast the data into a
class of passenger and here's the crew
as we see over here again you see the
data animating each each cube
representing a person who is on the
Titanic animating to across the screen
to where it's being laid out in the
chart and we here see the most people
joined in Southampton there and now
we've colored the data by whether or not
they've survived so more people died on
the Titanic than have lived probably
about twice as much so this paradigm of
scrolling on the left is just a really
easy way to go through and tell each
each story of the data so we think this
is a really easy way to consume a data
story just by a simple scrolling gesture
you can go through multiple views of
that data with an easy-to-understand way
of interpreting what you're seeing
thanks a lot